他房子大概率下的话，
就刨除去他首付那部分，
剩下的这些年还的房贷以及相应的增值涨价部分，
你都可以要求分一半，
所以其实你占的比重还是挺大的，
因为你结婚时间长，
你能争取的利益还是很大的。
是怎么保证孩子的利益情况下，
尽快跟对方离婚，
我们是第二年领的证，
结了婚买了房，
当时付的首付，
男方出的钱，
女方没有出钱，
但是上了我的名字，
主代人是他，
第三年生的小孩，
15年买了第二套房，
也是我们两个人的名字，
主代人是他，
在买第三套房，
中间我们就谈分开，
他分开谈的条件就是孩子归他共同抚养。
我说可以，
我也不给你争这些东西，
但是我要求我也不能净身出户，
因为责任方或者说对家庭负责任的是你，
他也同意了，
我说第一套房我们家我没有出钱，
那么我也不要给，
孩子你也别要，
然后第二套房我要求分一半，
当时我要求卖掉，
他不愿意卖，
不愿意卖呢，
后来我们就僵持了很久，
2020年我们又买了第三套房，
当时因为我的户口不在这个城市，
我还是上了他的名字，
然后主贷人就是我，
这期间这套房子200多个，
我说你到底能给我多少缺的呢？
因为我要付到六成到七成，
我就跟他说，
你到底能给我多少差的，
我自己去想办法，
跟你就没有关系了，
只要做到你承诺的给我的那一。
我就行，
后来他就说我最多给你90个，
我说可以，
你就给我90个，
其他的事情我就不需要你管，
我们就他好条件，
然后把协议书也发给他了，
发给他这是期间呢，
因为我还有两年的样子，
就是我户口就可以上来，
然后我就说我想上户口，
他说可以，
包括这期间，
就是他们住的那套房，
是我们结婚买的第一套房，
他们前台在做，
跟他父母在住，
他说的是不要我出抚养费，
孩子其实不管是什么费用，
其实大大小小的，
除了他在那边的开销，
其他其实开销也都是我的，
因为孩子一直是我一个人带的。
19年的时候我开始工作，
然后现在我在自己创业，
去年户口拿到之后，
我就跟他说，
我说也将不去这么久了，
我说要不我们把那个小续给办一下，
我说那协议也发给你了，
我说你就改一下日期，
签好，
我们约个时间去就行，
他就给我反悔了，
他说这个协议我没有签，
不算数，
我说为什么呢？
我说你什么想法呢？
因为他比我大了6岁，
他觉得孩子已经13岁了，
他就跟我说，
他说你还年轻，
你还可以再婚，
你名下的财产不一定是我孩子的，
他的意思是他年纪大，
他不会再婚了，
就是他名下的东西呢，
会是我儿子的，
包括他爷爷奶奶名下也有，
然后他就说本身还好，
给我的那套还归我，
然后另外两套放在他名下，
等孩子长大了给不给他，
或者说由他的名义给这个孩子，
然后当时我就说我不同意，
前段时间。
四月份的时候，
他爷爷脑血栓住院，
后来恢复了之后，
我就找他奶奶谈过一次，
我说这个家我付出了很多，
我也没有要求分你们的财产，
我是来过日子的，
既然这个日子我过不下去，
我说如果你儿子要是为难，
我就会把孩子的抚养权要走，
孩子也一直是我在家，
包括现在也是我妈妈在家，
他们每个月给3500块钱，
那我一个人太忙就是带不过来，
就孩子好像不能跟他们在一起，
跟他们在一起性格就会出现问题，
就会暴躁，
就会暴力，
在学校里也是啊，
去年包括在学校里还跟别人打了一架，
之后我就跟我自己的妈妈商量，
我说你帮帮我这孩子，
不能跟他们在一起，
只能跟我在一起，
我说你这两年帮我帮到他初中毕业已经说了，
我说三观已经形成，
他已经长大了，
我说你先帮我这几年好，
现在就是这种状况，
你想要问我的问题是什么呢？
想怎么样保证孩子的利益和我的利益的情况下，
尽快跟他结束这段关系，
就我们现在已经不联系，
其实是这样的啊，
因为你们俩呢，
其中有一套房呢，
是男方的父母，
就是出的比较多，
男方出的比较多，
就是有一套房你是没有出钱的，
剩下的两套房呢，
都是在婚后的是吧？
对的，
就是第一套，
本来我觉得我挺占主动权的，
后来这个婚姻法一变，
我也不知道我主动权在哪里，
第一套房是这样，
我们是在一线城市买。
是我们必须要领结婚证的情况下才能买，
然后之前我咨询的是他说算婚后财产，
这商事也就出了三十几万，
当时出了三十几万，
然后婚后一直还贷，
还了这十几年，
对不对对对，
那么其实这套房子你也可以分钱的，
这套房子大概率下的话，
就刨除去他首付那一部分，
剩下的这些年还的房贷以及相应的增值涨价部分，
你都可以要求分一半，
所以其实你占的比重还是挺大的，
因为你结婚时间长，
你能争取的利益还是很大的。
另外那两套房就不用说了，
是在你们婚后买的，
肯定是夫妻共同财产公平的来分，
所以呢，
你能争取到的利益呢，
不看这几套房的差价怎么样了，
反正你能争取到的利益是你们这些年的还贷部分，
增值部分你都能分一半，
第二套、
第三套房子更不用说了，
你都能分一半，
不要有什么羞耻感，
不要怕别人觉得说，
哎呀，
我当初图你们家户口了，
我当初图你的条件好了，
不要怕这个不图意，
我能看到你啊，
我不要走到出生的那个地步，
就我没有时间跟他折腾，
我也没有说这些东西要多分，
在我们一下，
我想保证的是在孩子一下，
这个事情只能是人家同意才行，
人家不是不同意嘛，
人家不同意那就行不通，
包括我跟他爷爷奶奶也沟通了，
他爷爷奶奶意思就是让我放心，
他说这些东西任何人都得不到，
只能是他的，
我就跟他们说，
我说你们到时候我说，
我相信你说的这句话，
但是如果你。
那到时候两眼一闭，
就最后还是你儿子说了算，
我说我不能同意去做公正赠与啊，
就是我现在没有贸然的去跟他去谈，
就我跟他爷爷奶奶先沟通过一次了，
爷爷奶奶意思就是不要去搞这些东西，
他说孩子到最后还是跟你亲了，
就是我现在就说到这里，
我突然就想到，
就是其实他们现在为什么反悔了，
我觉得他们的意思就是孩子一直是你在带，
一直跟你亲，
如果我们老把这些财产给了孩子，
这个孩子跟了你就可以给你了，
是这样的啊，
就是打仗打不回来的东西，
谈判桌上是不可能谈回来的，
你理解这个逻辑吗？
我理解，
所以我就想问，
我最后我要去走这个的话，
那么我能得到的就是除了第一套房，
第一套房三十几万，
当时也是他付的，
但是当中有15万是他父母给的，
我们也有还给他，
但是就是说这个大家都是知道的，
但是我不知道到最后大家能不能认这个事情，
那得有证据，
要么有录音证据啊，
可能更多的时候是他要去提证据，
而不是你提证据，
为啥呢？
因为第一套房也是你俩结婚之后买下来的，
所以呢，
得他去证明他花的哪些钱是他婚前的，
他花的哪些钱是他爸妈，
比如那婚后，
就是婚后生孩子之前我在工作，
生孩子之后从14年到一九年我都没有工作啊，
这个不重要，
他挣钱也是对家庭的贡献，
这两个贡献在法律上的话。
没有高价之分，
把起一分钱都没有出，
这个东西就是要硬气，
是我一分钱没有出，
但是我在家带孩子是吧，
这也是价值，
当然也没必要跟他谈，
我感觉没要跟这样的人去赌这个戏，
去看这个对，
所以我说我在行动之前，
前天你联的系了师，
只有一打促谈，
反正基本上这三套房的话就是半儿皮了，
原则上记得点赞关注哦。